how do we gather enough energy to do a
high jump run a sub five minute mile or
even just walk around the block after a
day of work these all depend on your
body processing fuel to make energy
for us this fuel takes the form of food
and water our bodies are able to convert
the food and water that we consume into
compounds that our cells can use for
energy
at the molecular level most of this
energy is stored in the form of
adenosine triphosphate or ATP and the
processes to create and use these ATP
molecules are collectively known as your
metabolism
your metabolism involves multiple steps
many enzymes and overlapping paths there
are also many checkpoints that ensure
everything is working properly
metabolism can be impacted in many ways
for example eating different foods
exercising or disease
let's walk through some of these details
together
the major metabolic pathways are those
for carbohydrates or sugars fatty acids
or fats and ketones once these foods
have been digested in our stomach and
intestines the nutrients head on into
our bloodstream and off to the cells
that need them
once inside the cell the broken down
products of nutrients are used to fuel
production of ATP
this can happen both inside and outside
the mitochondria an organelle famous for
being the PowerHouse of the cell most of
these nutrients get broken down into
acetyl COA if this is inside the
mitochondrion this metabolite enters the
Krebs cycle also known as tricarboxylic
acid cycle
this cycle is named after Hans Krebs who
first described it in 1957.
the Krebs cycle uses acetyl-coa to
produce much of the ATP produced within
the cell our knowledge of how metabolism
Works allows us to understand what
happens when things go wrong resulting
in disease we can use clever Imaging
methods to study metabolism at multiple
levels such as in cells tissues and
entire living organisms these methods
can use massive magnets magnetic
resonance imaging or MRI or radioactive
versions of fuels to look inside the
body
we can also extract cells and tissues
from these organisms and use methods
such as mass spectrometry to provide
even more information on a huge number
of metabolites that our bodies make from
food when things go wrong metabolism can
be a key factor in disease for example
the healthy heart uses fats and sugars
in a 70 to 30 ratio but in type 2
diabetes the amount of fat it uses
increases even further as it responds to
the higher levels of circulating fat in
the bloodstream
the healthy brain runs almost entirely
on sugar but in Alzheimer's disease the
brain's ability to use sugar goes down
research is underway to figure out
exactly why this is this even happens to
some extent in normal aging various
medicines are changes to Lifestyle can
be used to return the metabolism to
normal
lifestyle changes can be powerful such
as improvements in diet or more exercise
as they not only improve disease
symptoms but also lower the risk for
many other diseases fun fact there are
Laboratories with metabolic Chambers in
which volunteers live for short periods
of time everything that they eat and
even excrete can be measured allowing us
to examine the effect of different diets
exercise or disrupted sleep on how fuels
are broken down it's important to
carefully control metabolic experiments
since what volunteers had for breakfast
might influence the results
we are each unique one in eight billion
and metabolism is a perfect example of
that we all vary in how we process and
store food how much we exercise and
regulate heat but the underlying
pathways are mostly the same so we can
all expect to keep making that ATP to
get us up in the morning and around the
block